las negras importan también en brasil
bajo ese lema cientos de personas se
movilizaron en portoalegre para repudiar
el asesinato de hecho alberto silveira
freitas un hombre negro que murió tras
recibir una paliza de dos vigilantes en
un supermercado de la red carrefour las
protestas se replicaron en otras
ciudades del país justo en el día de la
conciencia negra que marca la lucha por
los derechos de los afrodescendientes en
brasil en río los manifestantes
ingresaron en una sucursal de la firma
francesa para repudiar los hechos ser
negro en brasil significa que te roban
tu humanidad te roban todos tus derechos
no tienes la oportunidad de ir y venir
en paz tienes el sistema de seguridad
diseñado para tenerte como acusado
incluso cuando eres la víctima en sao
paulo una movilización partido desde el
museo de la ciudad hasta las afueras de
otro local del supermercado para
denunciar lo que califican de racismo
estructural en el país
lo que vimos en portoalegre es la
expresión más despreciable del racismo
estructural del racismo institucional y
de cuanto se mantiene en brazo
la herencia de los paises esclavizadores
que actuaron en las américas
las protestas mayormente pacíficas se
terminaron con algunos destrozos en sao
paulo los manifestantes también
rechazaron las políticas del gobierno de
saiz bolsonaro su vicepresidente de
hamilton morado desestimó que la muerte
de joao alberto sea un episodio de
discriminación racial y aseguró que en
brasil no existe racismo